increasing work capacity is one of the
most effective ways to increase size and
strength and one of the most
underutilized in fact focusing on work
capacity can lead to some truly
superhuman feats and you'll see what I
mean
later on in this video simply put work
capacity describes your ability to train
for an extended period of time the
greater your work capacity the longer
you can train before fitness becomes a
limiting factor if you've ever felt like
you could have done more push-ups or
more pull-ups if you weren't out breath
then work capacity is probably something
that you need to focus on this is
actually one of the main focuses of
CrossFit by the way which is why they're
able to do things like tens or even
hundreds of clean and presses without
tiring out but essentially seeing as
work capacity allows you to train for
longer and harder that means you can
train more and it means you can get more
results in that way it is a kind of
secret sauce when it comes to strength
and conditioning train more get more
results it's that simple if you want to
increase your work capacity what do you
need to do well obviously starting with
a basic level of fitness is rather a
good idea that means you need to have a
decent vo2 max it means you need to
better control your breathing whilst
you're lifting so you're not getting out
of breath however that is just one small
part of it it's not even the main part
that's because work capacity is actually
much more specific than that work
capacity means being able to do more of
the thing that you want to be able to do
lots of and learning to run long
distances doesn't necessarily guarantee
that you're gonna be able to do massive
rep ranges when it comes to your squats
so you're dead lit these are different
muscles it uses different energy systems
there's just only a certain amount of
crossover for example when lifting
weights you really if ever use your
aerobic energy system then other aspects
are more involved in what capacity when
it comes to curling weight such as your
muscular endurance which is the ability
of your muscles to exert force of a
moderate amount over an extended period
of time this has to do with things like
glasses in stores and blood supply and
all kinds of other stuff
and of course there's a danger to adding
a lot of cardio into a strength-based
training routine if you add your cardio
the end of your workouts then you risk
creating a kind of catabolic cocktail of
hormones that might impair your muscle
growth but if you do your cardio at the
beginning of the workout then you'll be
out of breath and you'll be more like to
injure yourself and less likely to have
an effective workout in general so what
they do instead you simply do more of
the thing that you want to do in this
case that means increasing the volume
and the intensity of your workouts
gradually over time thereby testing your
ability to keep going without wearing
out Ross ethically author of the world's
fittest book which is an excellent book
by the way I recommend you check it out
recommend something that he calls horse
power programming this involves a couple
of different strategies for increasing
your work capacity the first of which is
simply to add an extra set onto each
exercise you do this by performing an
extra rep at the end on its own then
increasing those reps one by one each
time you do a workout until eventually
you're doing a whole extra set and then
once you're doing four sets or however
many you can increase the weight and go
back to three and then build up to doing
poor again this works because you're
basically just increasing the amount of
volume thereby increasing your work
capacity however this isn't my favorite
strategy for a couple of reasons the
first is that the length of your
workouts is gonna be very variable now
if you're doing three sets of everything
or four sets of everything then that's
going to drastically increase the amount
of time that you're in the gym and you
might not have that much time it also
increases the risk of injury because of
course you're lifting more weight at a
point of exhaustion and then there's the
whole kettle of fish that is over
training or over reaching there's a
whole video on that and I recommend you
watch that because actually has a lots
to do with this one this is why I prefer
Ross's alternative recommendation which
is to do a kind of finisher at the end
of your workouts and this isn't just a
pure cardiac finisher it's a resistance
cardio finisher that means that you're
combining cardio with some form of
resistance like a weight or like a
pulley or something like that or your
body weight and for bonus points try
make sure that the finisher targets the
same muscles as the workout that you're
doing so an example of this might be to
perform a shoulder workout let's do ten
intervals of two minutes on the battle
ropes you should give this a try it
really pains their shoulders that's
because you're sending tons of blood to
the area you've just trained thereby
causing occlusion
and the build-up of metabolites
basically you're causing a lot of
metabolic stress after you've just done
a whole workout on the area this can
potentially increase your growth as well
as improving your work capacity by
forcing you to keep on going at the
point where you would normally go home
and call it a day there's one more
technique that you can use that's even
more interesting and it's one that ross
also recommends but in a different
context basically you're just going to
add more exercise targeting the same
muscle group at the end of each workout
but this is going to be with a light
weight is going to be a simple movement
and it's going to be non eccentric
concentric only so by simple movement we
mean it's gonna be single joint like a
curl or a common movement pattern like
running or pulling it needs to be low
weight or non-load-bearing or low impact
and finally it needs to be concentric
only concentric only means that you're
only contracting the muscles concentric
part of the movement is where you
shorten the muscle and contract it the
eccentric part is where you lengthen the
muscle normally the eccentric part is
the part where you put the weight back
down an amortization is the part in
between where you switch from concentric
to eccentric there's a new word for you
potentially the eccentric portion of the
movement as most of you will know is
incredibly important because by
lengthening the muscle you can actually
bear more weight than you can when you
shorten it you can lower more weight
than you can lift at the same time this
is when a lot of the muscle damage
occurs to lots of the micro-tears and
that's what leads to strength gains and
increases in size however the eccentric
portion is also the part of the exercise
that causes the Dom's
delayed onset muscle soreness also known
as ouchies the next day at the same time
that's probably what causes the most
information and it can lead to
overtraining and injury so basically by
eliminating that parts of the exercise
and just focusing on concentric we were
able to get some of the benefits still
but at the same time we're avoiding that
Dom's and that pain so in theory after
doing a whole pull workout you could go
and flip tires that's concentric only
exercise because you're just pushing
you're not lowering the tire and you
wouldn't have any problem the next day
and you could do this for large reps at
a high intensity and high volume to
increase your work capacity without the
downsides Ross Edgar Lee used this same
technique in order to achieve his
world's highest rope climb which was the
length of Everest I believe he was able
to train his biceps every
all day using that technique as well as
climbing up a rope and then just walking
down step allows us to get back down
using entirely concentric movement he
also managed to run a mouth and towing a
car which once again is an entirely
concentric movement so like I said by
training in this way you can achieve
some truly superhuman feats and research
printed in the journal of strength and
conditioning shows us that concentric
only exercise is still capable of
producing strength and size gains of
39.7%
and 3.3 percent respectively in that
particular study of course another way
to increase your work capacity is just
to increase the number of repetitions
you're doing in each set and the best
way to do this is to drop the amount of
weight you're using the American Society
of Sports Medicine recommends that you
train with around 50 percent of your 1
rep max and that you shorten your rest
periods in order to increase work
capacity it's the set principle again
specific adaptation to impose demands if
you want to be able to do more curls
then do curls for longer they're going
into this high rep ranges bodybuilder
style will increase your muscle
endurance even if it isn't the best
option for pure strength potentially
through sarcoplasmic hypertrophy or
increasing the amount of sarcoplasm the
amount of glycogen stored in your muscle
and using those along the rep ranges
you're even increasing capillary density
so creating more blood supply to the
muscle this is yet another really good
reason to use drop sets that means that
you're lifting as much as you can
getting to failure and then lowering the
weight or choosing an easier exercise to
continue going for a high rep range
there by training your strength and then
your endurance in a single workout of
course you could just do work capacity
days and integrate them into your
workout so you'd be doing some workouts
that were more strength based and some
that were more endurance based and on
those days you'd of course trimmed like
to weight simpler movements more
concentric only exercises etc so there
you go that's work capacity those are a
few ways you can increase it let me know
in the comments down below if I missed
anything you have any cool tips for
boosting work capacity I mean take home
from this that I think is just to make
sure your training work capacity your
new form is burning through more power
than your body can supply you should
have waited until you were used to this
form and knew how to regulate it before
you started picking fights a lot of
people ignore it but it's the difference
between being fit and strong or just
strong and out of shape
thanks a ton for watching I've got lots
more stuff on the way suit I've been
doing my Knightly training I've got
video coming on increasing jump heights
I've got video coming on Shaolin
training with all that sounds awesome
then thanks a ton for watching and I'll
see you next time bye for now
you